this conference will now be recorded
hi everyone thank you for tuning in to
this pre-recorded session
for meet the consumer science team
series for
cv edition so um for any questions you
have regarding the team presentations or
interested in
any one-on-one follow-up conversations
with any of our researchers
please reach out to our alias consumer
science at amazon.com
during this session you will hear from
three of our amazon
teams who are using research and cv to
enhance our customers experience across
video augmented reality search and much
more
so today we're actually going to be
featuring senior applied scientist
frederick davernay from the imaging
science team
i'm senior applied science manager
michael liu from visual search
and from the home innovation team senior
applied science manager
alicia martinez and so without further
ado i'd like to introduce
um frederick with image sciences
thank you um hello
my name is frederic de vernay i am
and i am currently with the amazon
imaging technology team so um
i've been at amazon for three years and
before that i was a researcher at
inria in france doing 3d computer vision
today i will present the work we are
pursuing
on scaling photorealistic 3d content
creation
creation with 3d computer vision and
machine learning
so photorealistic 3d content is being
used
for several experiences available on
amazon.com
this includes the detail page where the
product photo
is sometimes replaced by a 3d render of
higher quality
than the original foil this also
includes the 360 spin experience
which displays a ratios version
of the rotating 3d object
also we have the interactive shopping
experience
where furniture in the showroom can be
mixed and matched
and all these furniture are actually 3d
models that are already traced
and we also have the augmented reality
experience
which allows you to view the product in
your room and will be detailed later by
of course you can imagine many more uses
for that 3d content for example to
generate synthetic
realistic home environment for machine
learning and robotics
so what is 3d content really well 3d
content is first
about geometry it has to be accurate
both in terms of general shape but also
in terms of small details which are
sometimes equally important for the
customer
it also has to be editable by artists
because we do not expect the computer
vision algorithm to give perfect results
a hundred percent of the time
so we prefer higher level primitives and
movable parts
rather than the triangle mesh which is
output by
most 3d reconstruction methods
but as you can see geometry is not
everything
and 3d content is also about
materials materials have to be
photorealistic which means they cannot
be reduced to a texture
extracted from the images they contain
several components to enable physically
based rendering
and have to be of high resolution so
that they can be viewed
and rendered from any distance and under
any lighting this looks like a very
difficult problem to solve
but 3d artists are able to create
these high quality 3d models from just
a few photographs typically one to five
how do they do
well the thing is we have seen lots of
examples of
chairs and other 3d objects in our lives
and so happy artists and we
and we have learned about the many
possible appearances and arrangements of
parts in these objects so why not
learn from existing 3d models and use
that
in a computer vision algorithm to
reconstruct these 3d shapes
from just a few images and it's the same
for materials
we can immediately recognize a wood
or a leather grain
a given type of fabric or
a metal finish from a single image
we can learn to recognize these
materials and build representations that
have more texture resolution
than the original images
so to solve the problem of
photorealistic 3d content creation
what we propose is to use
reference corpus model
with tens of thousands of artist-made
photographic 3d models
and combine machine learning
3d computer vision and computer graphics
to build a photorealistic 3d model
from a few images more specifically
we use techniques such as shape
retrieval
automatic shape deformation and editing
to fit it
to the images and material segmentation
and recognition to build our artistic
3d models we are also
pursuing another research direction
which consists
in using recent neural rendering
techniques
to bypass the explicit creation of a 3d
model
and directly generate the novel views
our goal with the imaging science system
is to build
3d models for all products in the
imaging amazon category
not only chairs and so thank you for
listening and now i'll hand it over to
michael
for the next presentation
hello friedrich thanks project hello
everyone i'm michael lew
appliance science manager on the visual
search and augmented reality team at
amazon a little background of myself
i've been working at amazon close to 10
years
and i worked on most of the project that
i'm going to talk about
and all four features actually shipped
inside the amazon mobile shopping app
i really enjoy the fact that we're
building products that directly consumed
by millions of customers
and at the same time we kept innovating
our products through science
so today i'm going to talk about how
we've been applying computer vision
technologies
to help customer shop at amazon as our
team name suggests
we're chasing two directions the first
direction is that we use
visual signal to search products when
you see a product
as a physical store and you want to see
if there's a better price elsewhere
you will try to describe using words and
you want to use those words
to form a text search to find products
and we want to automate that process for
you
as you open the amazon app you will see
the camera icon
next to the search bar which is where
our feature sits
just like when you phrase the search
search query
by looking at the products the more
precise information you can provide the
better result you will get
we also try to extract as much variable
information from image
as possible to help the search problem
some of you may be familiar with the
image retrieval system we managed to
scale our solution to search from
millions of amazon products
within hundreds of milliseconds
in old days we zipped like features and
it's been replaced by different features
today
1d and 2d barcodes continue to be
popular because
they are accurate and fast decoding most
products have text
we use syntax recognition techniques to
extract text
and use those texts to refine our search
results
this is particularly helpful one text
can be used to
do fine growing classification the
product with little distinguishing
feature
a product that does not sold on amazon
we use
semantic understanding and visual
similarity to help finding similar
products
or products within the same category of
course this is not a solved problem
we believe the future of visual search
is to be a complementary text search
so we've been working with the amazon
search team to see how we can directly
turn an image into search query
and to fuse behavior behavior data into
the search results
another interesting thing is that we
learned the best result is not always
the visually closed
products see that since there are many
other factors like
price and seller etc so been trying to
improve our ranking algorithm
to ensure that we produce the most
relevant results
we have been working with the visual
search algorithm for more than a decade
now
built on top of our learnings two years
ago we have launched a new feature
called style snap
many of you probably remember the famous
blue versus gold dress arguments
sometimes fashion items can be really
difficult to describe precisely
their color pattern style so we develop
deep learning models to detect different
parts
of clothes and to learn feature
embeddings to find similar products
there's always a domain gap between the
inner wild and catalog
images so make sure that the embedding
we learned can
accommodate for that recently we have
expanded feature to
recognize also home furniture there are
many additional challenges
such as handling occluded objects and
different perspectives
we use 3d synthetic data to help in the
training process to bridge the gap
speaking of us 3d another direction that
our team are working on
is to let customer view products in 3d
in their own environments
using arguments reality technologies a
very big pinpoint for online shopping
is that they're not able to see the
product from every angle
let alone sit in their room and the
worst shopping experience is that
when you brought the item and you found
it does not fit you have to return it
so we developer ai technology to address
this problem
the first thing we need to do is
obviously the model creation fortunately
fredrik's team has generated many 3d
furniture models
that can directly rendering air however
objects like this
the one that i'm showing here have
complex structure texture and
material and requires a lot of time for
humans to model so we work with the
images science team to introduce
a scanning process and a new model
format to encode
object line fields at runtime we use our
in-house light field rendering
techniques
to render those models in 3d once you
enter the ar experience from the detail
page
the next step is to determine the
position on orientation of the camera
with respect to customer's room
so we use the visual initial odometry
system to
produce both the camera posts as well as
jack surface for customer to place
virtual objects on
on top of the zinc geometry information
we have been trying to add more semantic
understanding of
environments to bad cut better guide
customers through the experience
a couple of examples includes
understanding the wall to make sure that
the virtual object will not be placed
outside of room automatically finding
empty areas to place the virtual objects
last year we have released a new
development called savior room
we allow customers save their ai session
and reuse them across different
platforms
with this offline experience we're able
to add more computational power
to the sync understanding task and
extract even more information to help
customers
in their experience our long-term vision
is to create a digital replica of
customers room
and generate inspirational ideas that
fit well within that room
this year we also further expanded our
ar capability into other categories
we just launched a virtual trial feature
to glasses
and we believe our customers can benefit
from ar-based virtual trial for many
other categories
such as makeup jewelry etc we've been
working on
really state-of-the-art technologies in
both computer vision and computer
graphics
and we're looking for talent to join the
team thank you
i'll hand it to alicia for the next talk
thank you very much michael um so as a
first introduction to myself i work in a
department called home here at amazon
i am alesh martinez i've been working in
machine learning and computer vision for
the last 25 plus years
and i've been extremely active in the
cbpr community
so much so that i actually organized
cbpr in columbus back in 2014
and i've been involved as an area chair
in other
domains at cvpr for many many many years
i am creating a brand new team here at
amazon
dedicated to science and we are very
interested in basic and applied sciences
image especially mission learning
computer vision and
our goal is mostly to publish in
conferences like cvpr
so if you're interested we have plenty
of openings at all levels right now
looking for people so come join us yeah
we're going to have a lot of fun
our research that i have done with my
students
at ohio state when i'm a professor and
here at amazon
has been published at all these
conferences and top journals
we actually won the best paper award at
eccp
a few years ago and where one of the
finalists
for the best people award last year at
cbpr
uh we've also published papers in pembi
pnas
and many other places so i create the
excitement
to be creating this new team here at
amazon
the research that we do includes or
goes over pretty much every area that
you see
at cvpr so if you are publishing cpr
most likely we're interested and i'll
showcase a few
examples applications that amazon
is working on here at home that relate
to
the research meeting that includes the
research that we develop
and i just want to emphasize that we
work on the research component
and develop the ml and computer vision
not necessarily the final product that
you see
here in the slides so to begin with let
me
go over discover which is one of our
products
in home and discover it's just basically
a way for
our customers to easily find products
that they like
rather than just using a query search uh
using text
for products that are very difficult to
describe
we allow customers to scroll through a
variety of product types like furniture
home decor lighting kitchen and dining
etc that you see here maybe you're
interested in furniture so you can now
click in furniture
now you see a lot of products and now
you can start liking
and disliking products and you see as i
like and dislike
products the products are shown in the
image
change is because there is an embedding
space behind
us where we pop up uh
products that are more similar according
to that embedding space of the ones that
you like
and most dissimilar to the ones that you
dislike and
we're doing a lot of research on these
embedding spaces
uh there are a lot of algorithms using
cnns we're now obviously using also
transformers to see which ones were
better
etc so again exciting fundamental work
that we can do on this domain
uh the other project i want to showcase
here
is called uh shop the room
or most known as discover rooms is
actually a product that was showcased
also by amazon very recently
and it's a beautiful experience where
you actually can scroll through
hundreds of thousands of different rooms
you can even search
for them using filters such as
this one here where i can just say i'm
interested in california casual style
and then
the machine learning behind the system
was like the ones that
are from this style then you can also
search for similar
rooms again embedding spaces here to
determine where is the smaller room
now when you click on the room you have
all these products that are
tagged all these tags are automatically
created by
computer vision algorithms of object
detection product type detection
and then similarity models to determine
all the products in the amazon catalog
that are similar to the one
in that room so that allows customers to
explore
hundreds of thousands of rooms uh
very quickly in just a matter of minutes
and
select from the filters with regard to
room type we have living rooms bedrooms
kitchens bathrooms outdoors like
patios etc and you can scroll through
a variety of over a hundred different
product types right now that we tag with
the machine learning computer vision
algorithms
and then with the similarity i want to
just showed here you can actually then
go
and determine which are the most similar
asons
so you can actually scroll through
thousands and thousands of essentials
similar to the one
shown in the image find the one that you
really like
and compare prices shapes colors etc
it's a pretty cool uh prequel product
that we have
and again lots of ml behind it another
very exciting project that we have it's
called collections
and i prefer to call it an ai interior
designer
because basically this is your personal
interior designer
only that it's an ai interior designer
that uses computer vision and ml to
come up with suggestions so basically it
works if you're in detail page of a
product
like this coffee table here if you
scroll down in detail page you'll see
this widget
and you'll see these collections and
this collection of items are items that
combine
well with the seed item like the coffee
table here
and then when you find items that you
may like you click here
and then for that item obviously as well
you have
a new set of collections that you can
scroll through
again products that combine well with
this uh
central item this is a really hard
problem for machine learning i mean we
are trying to simulate what i
need an expert interior designer human
does right
how do you determine what are the
products that combine well
with the ones that you have at your home
so um
very exciting research very complicated
models
from ml and for computer vision that are
used here
this is a tremendous amount of research
especially using transformers that we're
applying to this uh fantastic
opportunities for you to work
on this also we are working with uh
michael's group
uh and other groups to add us into
stylus map where you have that little
camera that he showed
and so you can actually take a picture
of your own room and then we can
give you suggestions of collections for
that
and all this is already available so
it's pretty cool
uh how it works and uh the last project
i want to showcase here
is something that's extremely related to
what both frederick and michael have
presented
just how do we show these
three-dimensional models
into your own environment right and
that involves a lot of three-dimensional
vision three-division it's something
super important for frederick and for my
team so
please come in if you are interested
in this uh in this project or at least
talk to us
uh to learn more so here's basically
the experience you start with a central
item that you want to
show or you want to visualize in your
own room and then you just point your
camera
and uh algorithm will determine the
structure of your environment right and
we'll
place a three-dimensional model that
frederick's group has created
into that environment you can rotate the
model you can move around
and see how the product actually looks
from variety of vantage points
it's actually really cool the way these
things work
i think there's just tremendous amount
of opportunity
for these products to only get better
over the years as machine learning
computer vision
improves um the amount of collaboration
that there is within amazon
especially within science is really
really tremendous
we collaborate with obviously michael's
and frederick's groups
but we also agree with many other teams
that work in computer vision
and machine learning here at amazon my
team in particular
has open collaborations probably with
six or seven
or other teams right now at just this
very moment
to keep getting into more collaborations
and
i think that's another great reason to
work here
and with that i'll pass back to the host
perfect thank you everyone um
we do have like a couple minutes so if
you are up for it
we do have a couple of frequently asked
questions
that we receive from conference
attendees especially for
from cbpr and eccv so
i'll ask the question and feel free to
answer
um there is one that um someone
usually asks for each of the panelists
so
what kind of background or skill
um for example advanced mathematics
stats
computer science algorithms do you find
extremely
valuable in your day so as a manager or
you know as a scientist at amazon
i can probably get started with regard
to the science that we do
and then maybe michael and frederick can
follow up on
other types of more applied scientists
uh
the the type of scientists in my group
usually have a phd
you don't have to have a phd but you
have to have
lots of experience so 99 of the cases
that is someone with a phd in computer
vision or machine learning
or maybe statistics and math um
experience in doing this type of
research is very important
uh having papers at top conferences like
cvpr is important
and being a good coder it's really
important uh
you know it doesn't get easier
if you're not able to test a lot of
algorithms
we have the resources to test a lot of
algorithms and implement
different variants of the algorithms but
at the same time you have to have those
skills particularly in my case i find it
really useful to have a really strong
background
in linear algebra in statistics and
in computer vision machine learning
because that allows you to read the
new literature very quickly and adapt to
the
changes in uh research uh
areas or uh the the the different
topics that are coming up like
transformers recently
if you don't have that background you
might find it really hard to transition
quickly so
i encourage everyone to do their due
diligence
and really creating a strong background
on those domains
so yeah i want to echo what alicia
mentions um
yeah first i would say that
have a really good solid understanding
of mathematics
usually helps along the way right um and
many of the
latest advanced technologies are built
based on that
and once you have that have a really
strong curiosity
and making sure that you keep learning
the latest state-of-the-art techniques
because this field is progressing really
fast
right and the third thing i want to add
on that is
um don't brief read about your
your domain check with us amazon is
really large
there are many many teams working on a
lot of different problems
even if you're working on medical
imaging who knows maybe there's a team
that works
best for you as well so check with us
and um
yeah and um exactly in line with what
michael just said i mean
the nice thing about amazon is that
whatever your specialty is
there is a team at amazon that needs you
so
if you have a phd i think you can safely
apply and
and there is probably a team that needs
you
perfect great answer so we'll do one
more um
what are some of the most challenging
areas or problems
in the cv field today and why
uh i can start uh i think um and i guess
my answer will probably align with
uh frederick because i think uh there's
a there's
this particular problem called 3d
reconstruction and it can be a 3d
reconstruction of objects or it can be a
3d reconstruction of the
environments people have been starting
this field for a very long time
but even with the latest advance of
neural network i think we're still
getting to a certain percentage there's
still a very large gap on that
right particularly i think understanding
how the lighting affects
your overall um semantic understanding
how to decompose that
our human are really good at it i think
computers still
there's a long way to go to decompose
those factors and maybe not decompose
them
learn them all together and and really
try to
learn both the geometry and the semantic
information of the environment i think
it's still
a research topic that has has a lot of
things that we can
we can work on
richard do you want to go next um
yeah i think i think uh computer vision
has been very successful in the recent
years to to get
a coarse grain a coarse grained
description
of the the world around us so things
like classification
semantic segmentation and things like
that but uh
the very fine-grained problems such as
3d reconstruction and reconstruction of
the
svbrdf of the surface of the object are
really challenging problems that we are
looking forward to solve
my team is also interested in three
divisions so i
second everything that's been said thus
far um i would add to this that
reasoning in ai is one big
problem that has not since only been
addressed or has not been successfully
addressed
yet uh so object detection yeah
it sort of works uh in many environments
now
uh even in the wild but
reasoning about the environment human
behavior
modeling humans etc or very highly
non-deformable objects is something that
is making progress but still in its
infancy there is a tremendous amount of
research
in that area and go back to something
that michael said earlier
our three groups do not work in medical
imaging but there is a lot of tremendous
uh interest in medical imaging and there
are
gazillion of problems in medical imaging
they're really hard
and completely unsolved right now and it
doesn't seem that the current methods
that we have that we're using in cvpr
actually going to be sufficient to solve
these problems so there's
amazing research going on in that area
perfect um you guys are doing so well
okay i was just joking we're gonna do
one more question so
um how do you balance between production
efforts so deliverables
versus research efforts so innovation at
amazon
sure i can start um i i'd say
in my team the science team meaning my
team
within my department uh my team just as
a science
and we have our engineers who actually
do
all the productions products annotation
of what
we implement so in our case
90 of the work is just in innovation
and developing those latest
methods and publishing the research we
do collaborate obviously with the
engineers and
serve as you know a bridge between the
signs that we performed
and the product that they implement
i can go next uh so slightly different
from alicia's team our team actually
our scientists are directly working on
the production so approach we're taking
assets
and we try to create a portfolio for
every individual as well as for the
group
and portfolio meaning that maybe seventy
percent of the time you work on the
innovation uh thirty percent of time
you're working on the production
um you try to find a good ratio for
everyone so that's
make sure that at each individual
milestone you have deliverables
but as well as you have a long-term
vision that you're investing for
for maybe three to five years and that
way
i think it works for a lot of the groups
that has this kind of hybrids
um because you as a science team you
want to
not stop we want to think about for the
long term but at the
same time you also want to be able to
have
immediate impact on your customer
yes so we we are working with
production goals very often but what i
what i noticed when working at
amazon is that actually uh taking the
exercise of writing an actual paper
an actual scientific paper uh actually
boosts
the the research and enables new results
that that were often unexpected so
uh i i i
i help many of the scientists on our
team to
write those papers because usually
there's a big jump
in the technology when we write a paper
so great answers so i just want to thank
you know my panelists today and for
taking the time to
speak about your teams give us a glimpse
of your projects and what you're doing
and innovating
and thank you audience for joining us
today and tuning in so again if you have
any questions or interested in
any one-on-one follow-up conversations
with any of our researchers
um reach out to our alias consumer
science at amazon.com
so thank you everyone thank you
this conference will now be recorded